I would say a bond between the inmate
and the horse is one of the most
important things that they learn when
they actually start to bond to that
horse they will become better trainers
they will become better people I think
that's good that they feel that much
pride in their horses it's good to have
pride in something especially in prison
[Music]
take the goats right up behind his ears
a little bit with that rope and when
that gets up there he might jump I'm
pretty good my name is Hank curry
I'm the head horse trainer here at the
Northern Nevada Correctional Center I've
been here 15 years now and I'm in charge
of about 20 to 25 inmates
we're taking a completely wild horse and
trying to domesticate them get them
where their a gentle musical horse the
inmates put in applications to come to
work out here according to their
behavior in prison we review all of that
and try to decide whether or not they
could possibly become horse trainers to
start out with we take a totally wild
horse and I have my guys actually put
them in a round drill we don't allow
them to rope them or anything else they
have to actually make contact with their
hands most of the inmates that may be
ridden a horse once or twice in their
life so it takes a lot of guests and it
takes a lot of determination this guy
right here didn't want nothing to do
with me and now he's you know my little
buddy and he follows me everywhere I go
it's just a moment where you bond you
know and you become you know like best
friends this guy only did it within the
last few weeks it's pretty amazing I
mean I'm not doing time until I go back
to camp you know and that's when the
clock starts for me as far as realizing
where I'm at when I'm out here I'm free
in the last few years we've developed a
lot of horses that have been used by the
Fish and Game Wardens the Forestry
Service the Sheriff's Department
actually has a amount of group and those
were horses trained by this program I
think that you know this job is kind of
inspirational it's not like regular
prison where everybody's running around
being foul-mouthed you know being a
tough guy and everything else doesn't
work out here horses don't care who you
are how big or how tough you know they
will equalize the playing field that you
want to play tap I see a great deal of
change and all these guys they seem to
mature they're functioning they know how
to work you know how to hold a job so
often it's it's changed their lives
you